after the last video on the cosmic
microwave background radiation Midori
fan 10 asked this question and I want to
do a whole video on it because it's a
really good question
and he or she I'm sorry Midori fan 10 I
don't know whether you are he or she if
all this radiation is reaching us now
does that mean that there will be a
point in time that there will be a point
in time further in the future when there
will be no where when there will no
longer be any cosmic microwave
background radiation because it is all
already past a spy or does it not work
like that so let's think about it a
little bit just as a review what we're
saying is if you go far as you go as you
as light from further and further away
in the universe gets to us we're
actually looking not only at light
that's traveled a long distance but
we're looking at light that left a point
in space a long time ago and so when
we're looking at things at the edge of
the observable universe the photons that
are reaching our eyes right here they
left they look like they're over here we
actually now know that those coordinates
in space right now are much closer to 46
billion light-years away not 13.7 but
billion but this diagram is done based
on how long the light from that object
has taken to get here so when we look at
light from this object here not only are
we seeing it from that point in space
but we're also seeing it from 13.7
billion years ago or we're seeing it
from that point in time where we had
just this hydrogen haze this hydrogen
plasma that was uniform all around the
universe hadn't hadn't started to become
differentiated into stars and galaxies
was all this one uniform plasma and
because of that we anytime we look at
photons from that distance photons that
were emitted within three four hundred
thousand years of the beginning of the
universe it just they they're just this
this uniformity from that distance and
that's what we call the cosmic
background radiation so the question is
if we wait a billion years if we were to
wait a billion years this the stuff that
was emitting there was the stuff that
was a haze 13.7 billion years ago if you
go a billion years forward it won't
no longer behaves it will it will have
started to differentiate itself so if we
were to forward a billion years it is
true the things that are 13.7 that the
the photons that have taken 13.7 billion
years to reach us a billion years from
now those won't be photons from that
hydrogen plasma or kind of white-hot
haze those will be photons from a more
differentiated universe from early stars
and it'll be and it won't be uniform
anymore so you might say Oh Midori fan
10 maybe you're right maybe we're out of
cosmic microwave background radiation
but you have to think about it this is
not the the true boundary of the
universe there's more stuff out here
there's more stuff out here outside of
our current observable universe outside
of observable universe of our current
observable universe outside of
observable unit the universe and so a
billion years from now instead of
talking about the photons that have
taken us thirteen that have taken 13.7
billion years to reach us a billion
years from now in a billion years 1
billion years if I were to make this
video a billion years from now I would
be talking about the photons that are
taking us fourteen point seven billion
years fourteen point seven billion years
to reach and those photons aren't going
to be from these type of objects they're
they're going to be from stuff out here
our observable universe will have grown
we will be able to observe more of the
universe because that more time would
have been passed to get photons from
further out but those same photons from
farther out a billion years from now
would still be going 14.7 that they
would have been emitted fourteen point
seven billion years ago during that
hydrogen plasma haze so we would still
have that background radiation it would
just be coming from a point further and
further out so hopefully that makes
sense and I want to make it very clear
and I say this in the patent in the last
video because this could be very
confusing when when these this radiation
this cosmic background radiation this
Relic radiation
we're getting now when that was emitted
the universe was much smaller the
universe was much smaller and let's say
let's just say this part of the universe
this isn't the whole universe here this
was just the observable part let's say
this whole observable part was like this
and the whole thing the whole thing was
this haze this whole thing was a haze
but the only reason why only this part
looks like a haze is because those
photons are the ones that left 13.7
billion years ago the stuff that over
here we're seeing a later stage in the
development of the universe because
those photons only left six billion
years ago the photons that left from
here 13.7 billion years ago when this
was and that in that primitive state in
that in that hydrogen plasma state those
photons have passed to survive a good
bit ago so hopefully that that kind of
gives you a better sense of what we
talked about and why it from every point
in the universe if you look out 13.7
billion years right now you will see
this this this cosmic background
radiation because you will have you will
be you will be observing photons that
were emitted 13.7 billion years ago and
13.7 billion years ago the only
radiation that was being emitted was
being emitted by this by this come this
this this this plasma hydrogen a
white-hot a you know fog or haze or
whatever you want to call it so
hopefully that answers your question we
will not run out of cosmic microwave
background radiation assuming and in the
hot extremely high probability that
their stuff out here especially
especially considering their could
remember we could very well be a ton of
stuff a ton of stuff out here and I'll
even tell you this so one the universe
is based on many models far larger far
far far larger almost unimaginably
larger than this observable universe
right over here so in that case we will
never run out based on the argument we
just had and as maybe even more bizarre
reality is whatever universe that is not
that much larger even and I'll do a
future video on a universe that might
even be smaller than this because you
could imagine then you have these
photons let's say this point right over
here this point over here 13.7 billion
years ago when it was in that primitive
state it might have released some
photons those
Donn's passed us up a while ago but if
this was if this was the extent of the
universe those photons would go to one
end of the universe and then come back
out of the other and so that they would
have another chance to pass us by again
and so if you think about it that way
even if there isn't a ton of stuff
outside of here we'd still have those
same photons going one side of the
universe and coming out on the other
side of our 4 of the surface of our
four-dimensional sphere I guess is the
best way to think about it if that
doesn't confuse you too much but but the
simple answer is we will not run out of
cosmic cosmic microwave background
radiation it should always be there